momento de la actualización deportiva en
france 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero luís méndez luis
bienvenido iniciamos hablando de fútbol
porque continúa la acción de la copa
américa femenina así es valiente una
acción del grupo ya primera hora la
selección de chile actual subcampeona de
este torneo cayó 3 goles por 2 frente a
su similar de paraguay para conocer
detalles de este partido vamos a la
ciudad de cali en colombia porque allí
se encuentra nuestra compañera estefanía
montero
vibrante partido se vivió en el pascual
guerrero en el debut de la selección
chilena en este grupo a tres goles por
dos o el resultado ante la selección
paraguaya un partido disputado lleno de
goles y sobre todo vivido en cada una de
las áreas hablamos con la volante yanara
aedo y nos contó que pasó en este
partido ya que se debió la derrota
siempre que jugamos con ella eran
empates o nunca fue un rival fácil así
que la verdad que era algo que se sabía
no esperábamos los goles tan rápidos así
que nada corregir errores e ir a buscar
jugadores
por el lado de la selección paraguaya
hablamos con la figura de la cancha- y
autora del tanto de uno de los tantos
que marcó la selección paraguaya jessica
martínez esto nos dijo sobre el partido
y lo que significó esta victoria no
estamos muy contentos muy felices por la
primera victoria que estábamos buscando
y ahora
ahora disfrutar del triunfo y ya después
pensar en bolivia
en lo personal muy contenta por marcar
contra colombia y por volver a marcar
hoy y nada espero seguir marcando
mañana continúa el fútbol en esta copa
américa el grupo ve en el centenario de
armenia brasil se enfrentará a uruguay y
venezuela recibirá a perú
valentina la acción de este torneo
continuó con victoria de colombia que
mantiene su invicto al vencer a bolivia
con marcador de 3 goles por 0 colombia
lidera el grupo con dos triunfos en
igual cantidad de salidas por su parte
en la concacaf canadá superó a costa
rica 2 goles por 0 al tiempo que panamá
se impuso por la mínima diferencia a
trinidad y tobago